y
[Música]
en francia entra en vigor el polémico
pase vacunal que hace obligatoria la
aplicación del fármaco para poder
acceder a lugares de ocio ya no es
suficiente una prueba negativa de
coronavirus tenemos reportes desde parís
en ecuador los estudiantes podrán
regresar a clases presenciales de manera
voluntaria una decisión que dependerá de
los padres en la capital las autoridades
flexibilizaron algunas restricciones
debido a una reducción en el número de
contagios por kobe 19 tenemos reportes
de equipo
camerún el país anfitrión de la copa
africana de naciones busca su pase a los
cuartos de final de este torneo ante la
modesta comoras en un escenario muy
particular tenemos información de
nuestro enviado especial
feliz inicio de semana y bienvenidos a
una nueva emisión de noticias en france
24 los saluda andrés meza muñoz
iniciamos en francia porque a partir de
hoy los mayores de 16 años que deseen
entrar a bares restaurantes y cines
deberán estar vacunados contra el kobe
19 para ampliar esta noticia vamos hasta
parís con nuestra periodista natalia
ruiz natalia muy buenos días cuál es la
reacción a esta medida en las calles de
la capital
muy buenas tardes pues la verdad es que
ha sido digamos una jornada muy
tranquila tanto aquí en la capital
francesa como en realidad en todo el
país no se han presentado ni se ha
sabido de incidentes con la entrada en
vigor de este pase ya de vacunación ha
sido digamos que bueno hay 53 millones
de personas que ya están vacunadas así
que saben cómo es este día a día pero
son quizás esos 4 millones y medio de
franceses que todavía no se han vacunado
los que van a comenzar a ver las
dificultades que van a tener en su vida
diaria de no poder ir a un café no puede
ir ir a un restaurante de no poder
viajar en un bus en un tren en un avión
porque para todo esto necesitan estar
completamente vacunados el gobierno ha
querido ser flexible y de hecho ha
indicado que de aquí al próximo 15 de
febrero las personas que pues reciban la
primera dosis de la vacuna podrán tener
un pase de vacunación temporal
presentando además junto con este pues
un test negativo para poder entrar a
todos estos establecimientos de ocio
entre otros natalia ha incrementado la
tasa de vacunación previo a la entrada
en vigor de esta medida
bueno si lo digamos que los días
anteriores cuando se supo que se estaba
discutiendo todo este proyecto de ley en
la asamblea nacional según cifras
entregadas por el gobierno nacional más
de un millón de franceses corrieron a
hacerse vacunar pero en estos días pues
digamos que ese número de vacunas
diarias no pasan de los 26.000 como les
decía hay 53 millones de personas que
están vacunados eso representa grosso
modelo 80% de la población francesa y en
estos días pues habrá que esperar
también poco a poco cuando las personas
se den cuenta de las trabas que
significa no estar vacunado que quizás
bueno esta política pública pues se
tenga su efecto que es finalmente
presionar a estas personas para que
finalmente sea vacuna natale muchas
gracias por ese reporte desde parís y
entre tanto la organización mundial de
la salud informó que la pandemia podría
estar en una nueva fase de
estabilización en europa mientras que en
américa hay un aumento de casos pero
menos hospitalizaciones en ecuador por
ejemplo hay un promedio de 7 mil 800
nuevos contagios cada día 56
menos que el pico del 20 de enero por
esto las autoridades autorizaron el
regreso a la presencialidad en el
trabajo y en la escuela sin embargo los
padres son autónomos en esta decisión en
quito nuestro corresponsal gustavo
ortega no se explica ecuador cambia el
color amarillo ante una reducción de
casos a nivel nacional según cifras
oficiales
179 de 221 cantores cambian al color
amarillo y se modifican las
restricciones sanitarias y con ello
retorno de los estudiantes a las aulas
de clases pero con algunas
particularidades serán los padres de
familia quienes decidirán si llevarán o
no a sus hijos a los centros educativos
en los casos de las escuelas donde
asistan todos los grados en las ciudades
en color verde y amarillo podrán asistir
de manera presencial mientras que en las
ciudades que permanezcan en el semáforo
rojo la asistencia no será obligatoria y
poder ser voluntaria se debe dividir en
los estudiantes por grupos y horarios el
cierre o apertura de las escuelas genera
polémica en el país organizaciones
sociales y padres demandan la reapertura
las escuelas a causa del abandono
escolar el abuso infantil el embarazo de
adolescentes el suicidio infantil la
desnutrición u otros temas que se han
agudizado a causa de la pandemia
mientras que en otros casos existe temor
de algunos padres de familia por los
aforos que se realizan en las clases
ecuador busca retornar progresivamente y
priorizar en la asistencia presencial a
las escuelas en ciudades como en
guayaquil epicentro la pandemia en este
país su alcaldesa declaró que no
permitirá el regreso a las clases ante
el incremento de casos de kobe 19 en
esta entidad donde la atención se ha
enfocado en el contagio de los niños
según la autoridad municipal en
guayaquil los riesgos de contagio se
multiplican por 4 ante la variante o
micro en la entidad se registran 18
fallecimientos de adultos por día y el
año lectivo concluirá de manera virtual
serán sancionados las escuelas que
decidan acogerse a la normativa del
ejecutivo nacional
pasamos a alemania una de las cuatro
personas heridas tras un tiroteo en la
universidad de heidelberg falleció en el
hospital según informó la policía los
hechos ocurrieron cuando un hombre
armado ingresó a la sala de conferencias
de esa institución y abrió fuego
indiscriminadamente contra los
asistentes y luego se suicidó de acuerdo
con los medios de comunicación locales
el atacante era un estudiante pero las
autoridades no han brindado más
información sobre él
el máximo tribunal británico acepto que
julian assange a pele a la sentencia de
la corte suprema sobre su extradición a
estados unidos donde se le acusa por
hasta 18 cargos de espionaje
alva santana tiene los detalles
es un rayo de esperanza para el julian
assange el máximo tribunal de reino
unido autorizó al australiano apelar la
sentencia de la corte suprema que falló
a favor de su extradición a eeuu en
diciembre una victoria para el
informático y sus allegados por japón'
en corte de expresión se quejaban
lo que ha ocurrido en el tribunal es
precisamente lo que queríamos que
ocurriera el máximo tribunal certificó
que hemos planteado una cuestión del
derecho de importancia pública y tiene
motivos para conceder la apelación ahora
falta ver si la corte suprema decide
acoger ese recurso
dirección el anuncio es el último giro
en la lucha de assange por evitarse el
juzgado en eeuu donde se le imputan
hasta 18 cargos de espionaje por
publicar documentos clasificarlos en su
conocida plataforma wikileaks algo que
podría costarle décadas de prisión los
abogados de assange han advertido en
repetidas ocasiones que una extradición
sería fatídica para su salud mental y
que temen que las condiciones en una
prisión estadounidense sean muy duras
para el activista a pesar de las
garantías del ejecutivo de bailén evitar
a todos los que han examinado esas
supuestas garantías las han condenado y
juzgado como si no valiera ni el papel
en el que están escritas
el gobierno de estadounidense ya ha
prometido esas garantías antes y las ha
roto son ser organizaciones de derechos
humanos advierten que su traslado podría
poner en peligro la libertad de prensa
en el mundo ahora en medio del debate
sobre si assange es un informático o un
periodista la corte suprema deberá
decidir si acepta o no el recurso el
camero busca su pase a los cuartos de
final de la copa africana de naciones
ante la modesta comoras en un escenario
muy particular el equipo como eres se
tendrá que utilizar a un jugador de
campo como arquero porque los tres
porteros de la plantilla no están
disponibles lo explica nuestro enviado
especial a camerún federico cue
barberena
en el estadio en vez de allá donde se va
a disputar uno de los duelos esperados
de los octavos de final el local camerún
va a enfrentar a comoras equipo
debutante en una copa africana que ya se
metió entre los 16 mejores del torneo en
las horas previas en la atención ha
estado puesta en una situación
particular que ocurre con como horas no
tiene arqueros disponibles para este
encuentro dos de ellos se dieron
positivo por kobe 19 días atrás y el
tercero ben salim voy más se encuentra
lesionado en las últimas horas ali
ahamada uno de los arqueros que estaba
contagiado de kobe 19 se hizo una nueva
prueba en la que dio negativo y viajó de
garúa a yaundé para
ponerse a disposición de este encuentro
sin embargo la confederación africana de
fútbol no autorizó al jugador a entrar
al estadio siquiera para presenciar el
encuentro por lo que como horas salvo
que cambie la situación a último momento
tendrá que disputar este encuentro con
un jugador de campo ocupando la portería
por el lado camerún es mucho más alejado
de estancia de polémicas buscará
continuar con la buena forma que mostró
en la fase de grupos que lo llevó a ser
el primero en su zona y al erigirse como
uno de los candidatos sostenido también
en la localía y en el apoyo de su
público gran escenario para un encuentro
de los octavos de final que definirá a
uno de los clasificados entre los ocho
mejores del torneo
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web www punto frente 4 punto com
para seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]